he'll be oh wait did one of y'all send
me somebody was sending me vin diesel
but fat with a bit
bear bell yeah i used to be fine i've
seen those before yeah that's not you
know
crew ups and downs i know i'm i'm on my
we've been down
we've been down let's be real we've been
down but now y'all by the way my trainer
was like i could get he said you could
get
get this uh chiseled you trying to say
that about me no you said it about me
what do you say about me hey yeah you
he said yeah we really drive along here
yeah hello mark harley what's his name
hello hello oh look at my man
he said we could get like that hella
mark what's up dog he really said that
how he's got our back well let's do it
hello mark send me
let's do a challenge together you want
to weight loss challenge
i'm down for that all right wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait right now
yeah exactly gorgeous man i'm telling
you dude yeah he said he said
he goes like he goes yeah how much how
much how much weight do y'all want to
lose though
i'd like to drop 30. 30. i would like to
get down a little bit you shouldn't
practice
probably 40 wait four don't say it like
that 40 250
220 no five nine 220 230
that's still thick no
you're five nine got he's good i'm not
five nine what are you
five eleven five eleven two thirty when
i put my neck up i'm six
five five five eleven two thirty
copy that but five eleven two thirty
still thick
no i see a lot of mma guys that that's
five eleven
and they he's like go to work right
hello hello margaret he's like
what's he think he can get us down to
let's do a challenge
you know how rogan does the challenge
but he does it with all his fat friends
he's incredible
and then we're going to be like that
would be like the challenge is hill
sprinting
like we don't like sprints he's like but
i do every day
he said we could get like that's i i
don't think so i want to oh yeah
i can't i love him i love his positivity
and i i think we can
i don't think so yeah we can i've been
professional like that
yeah you don't think we can do that i
think so about me that ain't for us
yes it is yes it is brandy don't cut
yourself my shirt says steak boy
we do not have the genetics to get that
way you think so
not naturally if he wants to send us
some of that
mexico hot sauce you feel me and put it
in our veins
black market
uh desert taking pictures like that so
next year
do you really want to do like yeah let's
do a challenge okay when do we start
i want to be in there let me start after
my vacation okay that makes sense
so you want to start uh next tuesday i'm
down
that means when we go on the road we got
to be we got to be good
i'm cool with that i want to do it yeah
malok wants to join i want to join no
you don't need to
no no no everything every pound y'all
lose i'll gain i want to gain 30.
you don't think we could give him i want
to gain 30. that's not for us dude not
that we don't have nothing
he's a beast look at him yeah yeah i
like that i would love to hear how he
thinks we're gonna do it
he's like oh you gotta eat a leaf leaf a
[ __ ] lettuce leaf everything's
a leaf yeah that's it dog a leaf that's
how the old woman
body look when she was naked like a
little leaf yeah i don't know
i just don't i don't know dude
it'd be really tough what about like
yeah yeah no get that dick root out like
that
i wasn't even looking at that what did
they call that v a v thing
cut that v cut yeah i haven't had that
in a minute since my cheer days yeah we
should we should do a uh
uh uh i will let's wait let's figure it
out let's figure out like logistics or
whatever
stop drinking yeah yeah this just
doesn't let me know because you could
because there's not a lot of car look
there's not like
yeah i think you're good on that all
right beer beer you know you don't do
mixed drinks
never just yeah so you just do whiskey
on the rocks hey you're fine
talk to your boy let's set it up all
right we'll talk to him we'll do a
weight loss challenge and we'll get him
in here at the end let's take a look
okay
yeah let's do it um
jimmy used to be damned at 300 pounds i
know it's the funniest picture i've ever
seen in my life i've never seen it
do you have a chin we used 300
this was my sadie hawkins dance oh gosh
chin let me see i'm trying to find
that's you was quite a while ago
[Music]
the funniest [ __ ] picture yeah it's
worth it's worth the scroll that's not
that much
like do you look the same though chin
like i can see myself
sort of you can see yourself yeah
dude i don't know if i could find it now
it's so old
china is a dope ass instagram i mean i
know right i'm sorry
oh chin my girl didn't know you could
sing and i played she messaged me back
until i was like what did she message
you yeah she's like i should just say
she was like i played the hannah baron
song she's like uh chin can sing
yes she goes that's not channeling i
said where are my live things just said
the same thing
i said you know ghando's instagram one
of them yeah
literally singing genuine aren't you
there it is
oh ringo is such a great look at this
you saw wrinkled i did the commercial
for it
you did a commercial that's the song
we'll get to that in a minute yo that's
not true
you look like that yeah that's not chin
though
that's that hey that's that guy that big
uh guy in rush hour three when chris
tucker had to fight in that karate clown
that's him that's not you chin that is
[ __ ]
what what are you sitting on hey hey
that was a theme yeah i was like
scared she doesn't look real
it doesn't look yeah it's like wait wait
wait wait she's sitting on your lap you
guys holding hands right there right
hands like just will you chance here
check out that simple jack haircut
i got earrings on too damn don't hurt
him daddy don't
hurt him we're here looking for joontov
she looked like a bad guy then the
double dragon right
he looked like jacob he didn't like jake
the american dragon she is
yeah we still talk about really yeah
once in a while does she know you're a
dime piece now
i know what's up now who's laughing now
no yeah you had me uh
no she she [ __ ] hey she picked me
back then now sadie hawkins remembers oh
yeah oh she asked you out to the dance
what's up with your shoes
that's the last airben
you better believe they're james that's
why you can't see you hell yeah that's
[ __ ] gangster
you danced uh slow dancing could you
sing back then
no at least i didn't know i didn't have
the confidence i didn't know i could
you know when i found out i could sing
yeah when pagers you could do pagers
hey do you guys even remember pagers
yeah yeah my dad would always text me
his number and go star 911. i called
like what are you doing like
what the [ __ ] dude but carry on
um so what was i saying also pagers you
know you could do a greeting a lot of
times i would just sing something in the
beginning
and then i just remember hearing people
you know they try to call and hang up
so then they would before they hang out
they go oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] so i kept
hearing over and over and over again i'm
like oh [ __ ] i could actually sing
so then i started doing sing songs on
like well like welcome
to chin's [ __ ] even that freaking
let's get married as long as you i think
i did
oh that was fine i didn't walk uh walked
out of heaven
walked out of heaven that was my that
was my joint come on man how long
was that jen casey and jojo too oh how
long ago were you singing in the pager
that was like early college days i think
yeah
that's the voicemail you had to have the
song yeah yeah you i did i would just
sing you sing instead of so you wouldn't
play the song like i did like i had a
video like hell this male like beak you
know i'm back
and they mean you're really singing i
would actually just sing like a cappella
you should do it again chin
yeah meet me at the enter
yeah let's get you a pager man you guys
are doing pages let's do it on your
instagram
yeah you should wrap the part i'll be
honest
when i get off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what this front of a bunch of other
comics i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song